uh I was gonna ask you uh what was well
first of all I am a die-hard Suns fan I
have well LeBron's my goat but I have a
over mic yes okay so see I have like a I
have son's toys I got you I got it yeah
okay
why did you play for Mike D'Antoni ever
was it in New York yeah New York okay
why am I Dan phony
what was your experience with Mike
because I have heard very mixed things
mostly very negative things about Mike
yeah I mean I I don't go into hella
detail but you know it just you know I
just respect coaches that just tell you
the truth all the time you know what I'm
saying don't talk [__] behind my back
don't tell me one thing and then tell
somebody else or nothing you know what
I'm saying so that's the phony part of
it
um the other thing was like
I may be wrong and like I said you know
the one thing I say about athletes you
know we don't have a real concept of
reality right you know I'm saying that's
what makes us special that's the reason
why this 30 million you know 300 million
people that play basketball and aspire
to be Pros like 300 and it's only 450.
you know exactly you know that's it's
the reason for that I just felt like we
could have been a better team if we like
attempted to play defense like we
literally never did anything for defense
like nothing never practice a rotation
like nothing so I'm just like how do you
expect us to win if we can't defend you
understand what I'm saying and we used
to tell them that and you know one time
you know Larry Hughes fell out of the
the rotation because me and Larry went
to him before practice one day I was
like yo coach listen we understand like
defense isn't a priority but you know we
talked to all the players and we're all
willing to come in 30 minutes before
practice
all right bro we like and he like got
all emotional and upset and offensive
and like you think his defense he's just
like talk you think it's defense you
think it's defense we're like yes we
can't defend nobody we don't know
rotations we don't communicate yes and
he got all pissed off and you know that
that just really frustrated me and it
just made me not like him as much as a
coach now obviously I got numbers under
him you know what I'm saying which is
his style is seven seconds or less seven
seconds it's wide open it's about
getting as many shots as fast as you can
which can be considered bad basketball
you know depending on who you are the
sun's never won a ring and he's never
won a ring and that's and then it makes
for great regular season records and
then you just keep getting jobs yeah you
understand what I'm saying like the the
league and that's what we could cover
that another time too it's just like
they keep recycling the same coaches and
what you think you'll get a different
result why yeah you know what I'm saying
so that's a whole nother thing don't get
me started
so what years were you with the Knicks
uh I think I was the 2016
10 and 11. I got traded this so I got
traded there I think in 2010 was that
like amari's first year
no Amari came right after me okay so
should you were you on the team with
Amari
I left there went to Denver with Melo
and then mellow got traded halfway
through the season and then you ended up
playing with like Landry fields and like
no I played who was all who was all the
random Knicks uh so I played my error
was when I was there it was like okay
Thomas had came back for a second Tracy
McGrady played with us for a second
McGrady played on the nuggets the Knicks
on the night oh nuggets is uh it was
Nene okay Nene was a very underrated guy
um it was
mellow
uh Kenya Martin yeah but when Melo got
traded you played the year after with
that with those guys right with those
guys yeah yeah so that was J.R Smith Jr
uh what's my damn what's my uh uh Ty
Lawson Aaron to follow what was the
light-skinned dude that the Knicks
traded to the um Nick or that they they
traded into the Nuggets but he was like
kind of like borderline like you could
again this guy could be an All-Star
Aaron to follow no Aaron will fall
played for UCLA I'm talking about there
was like a forward was it a small
forward
he was a part of that Knicks mellow
trade oh uh Gallinari no
[__] that's who came Wilson Chandler
Wilson Channel okay that's what I'm
thinking now oh okay I said the name
yeah that's my dog yeah shout out to
Wilson Champion League shout out to
Wilson bro what would you consider your
because you've been a part of some dope
teams obviously shout out to the Pacers
I feel like the Pacers were like
one of those teams that when I think of
the best teams that never got a ring I
think of the Pacers I think I think of
the Suns
um you know I think of
a couple versions of the Suns uh [__] my
life
um and then I just you know but but the
Pacers I feel like legit were like
talently
if you look at the roster like one
through eight or nine like the best team
in the league a couple of years in a row
yeah man when I first came in the league
so you know when I first came to the
league it was the year after you know
Mike did the push off to uh Reggie and
hit the shot you know they win that
Series so you know they were so mad they
were licking their wounds they thought
that you know we were winning the next
year no [__] so it was a lockout
year when I came in so they were so
focused that they had training camp the
training camp started when training camp
was supposed to start because Reggie was
like so whenever the seasons do start
we'll be in better shape than anybody so
we literally they had us all everybody
was there except for I think Jalen Rose
and Dale Davis but everybody to a man
was there was Rick Smith on that team
Rick Smith was on the team too yeah so
bro we did doing all he was in and out
of the practice during that time because
he had bathroom so we worked our ass off
up until like maybe Thanksgiving and
then like we'll look like [__] ain't
about to happen and remember they didn't
start until like January or the next
year or whatever but
at that time the league was all about
vets so I was like who had the best vets
at that time you know what I'm saying
and we just ran into the Knicks and uh
Larry Johnson had that four-point play
the four-point play was crazy you know
what I'm saying and that pretty much
knocks us out the box takes I'm on
minimal way but then the next year man
we get to the finals you know what I'm
saying we get to the finals but we ran
into a [__]
unbelievable Kobe being Bryant and
[__] Shaq that you can't do nothing
with you know what I'm saying and even
we I'm gonna tell you the funny thing
about that [__] we thought we had a a
series altering moment when Jay Rose
Jalen Rose stepped under Kobe and made
him roll his ankle
we like you guys were kind of excited
like hey
hey guys old school basketball yeah
you're like this is that's right go sit
your [__] ass down yes all that like
that was yeah like everybody in the
locker room like yes we got this
[__] out type [__]
and [__] Kobe plays the next game
taped his [__] up kept it moving and not
only kept the movie had like 36 or
something
were you would you like did was that an
on-purpose thing you'll see guys always
try to slide under the landings well
j-roll said I mean I think he's said it
himself he did it on purpose yeah yeah
like you know you know you don't know
that you're going to make him roll his
ankle but you hope something happened
yeah you know what I'm saying and uh
like I said during that time it was no
hoes bars it was just like survival of
the fittest you know what I'm saying so
yeah I would say that it was done on
purpose
I'm assuming throughout that series you
had to have like eventually kind of
ended up on Shack by accident maybe
there was no no
okay I was uh about to have back surgery
did you ever did you ever like I got a
shack though what was it like guarding
because because they always say he's the
most dominant player of all time and and
Peak Shaq I just I just you know I don't
know what you can do really bro you pray
um
so when he was in Phoenix
um the big Cactus bro he was he was
rolling down the lane
and I rotated over to take a charge and
when I got there he's heavy I had
already made the commitment and I just
closed my eyes and I said God please
and he hit me and fell on top of me but
you know it just didn't hurt I was like
surprised like boom and I opened my eyes
and he looking right at me he was like
you look at you from Jersey other than
that I would have killed you
he's like looking dead on Tommy like
look you from Jersey I was like thank
you big fella
but Garden Shack was it was impossible
bro but you know when you when I'm
guarding him we gotta double team him so
it's just like I'm just holding them
holding them up as much as I can and
this was my Golden State days yeah you
know what I'm saying we play small balls
so that mean now he got to guard me on
yeah you're like the big guy on the team
you know what I'm saying so uh but we
had success like I said we beat him
every time you know what I'm saying but
uh Shaq uh
Shaq was a low bro